Right.
Well,
today I wanted to talk about changes
in education and the growth of popular
literacy in the 16th and
early 17th centuries. Uh,
one of the most important sets of changes
which were going on in the reign of
Elizabeth and the under the
early Stuart's. Okay. To
begin with a little context,
uh, looking back at the
late medieval period, uh,
it's been said of late medieval England
that at that time all education was
technical and vocational directed to
some particular occupation or function.
And the formal schooling that we tend to
think of when we use the term education
was really only part of that.
Uh,
if one thinks of education more broadly
in terms of the transmission of a
culture and it's skills
and values and so on,
then of course that was a much larger
thing than simply formal schooling.
And it involved not only schools
but the church, the household,
many ways in which people were
instructed for their roles in life.
So one can't say that medieval England
was in any way an uneducated society.
It was educated insofar as it
needed certain kinds of training.
But it was a relatively
unschooled society.
Very few children attended
any kind of formal school,
probably less than 10%
in the late 15th century.
Formal schooling was reserved then
for specific occupations at that time,
clergyman,
those who are going to be lawyers,
some merchants who might need skills
of reading and writing or even foreign
languages, um, some craftsman and so on.
It was certainly not simply a clerical
monopoly as sometimes people think.
Nonetheless,
it was restricted in its scope and
tailored to quite specific occupational
needs.
Now at the turn of the 16th century,
that situation began to change and by the
late 16th century it was changing very
rapidly and new enthusiasm emerged in
this period for formal schooling at all
levels. Uh, why should that be so?
Well that seemed to have been two main
cultural influences on that development
affecting different parts of society.
First of all,
there was the influence of renaissance
humanism affecting mainly the social
elite. Um, when we speak of
humanism in the 16th century,
we mean not the a rationalist secular
system of morality that one thinks of
today when using that term,
rather,
the term is used to describe what
people at the time referred to as new
learning,
the new learning which had emerged in
the 15th century and was sweeping all
before it in the early 16th century,
championed by scholars like Erasmus of
Rotterdam or in England, John College,
the Dean of St Paul's
Cathedral or Sir Thomas Moore
in educational terms,
humanism essentially involved
the study of ancient languages,
Latin, certainly increasingly
Greek, occasionally also Hebrew
and the philosophy,
the literature and the history produced
by the writers of classical antiquity.
So it's a process of recovering more
fully the works of classical antiquity and
making them more available
to a larger audience.
And all of this was for a purpose.
It was believed by humanist scholars
that classical education combined with
Christian morality,
morality would be a way of reviving virtue
in public life and creating order and
harmony in the Commonwealth would be a
way of training virtuous princes and util
subjects. That was essentially
the humanist ideal. In a way.
They were trying to get back to the
notion of an educated aristocracy,
which had certainly been the
case in the Roman Empire. Um,
the aristocracy of late medieval England
of course, was largely a military one,
but they wanted them to be scholars too,
just as the great figures of
classical antiquity had been.
And this was to prove up
profoundly influential ideal.
It was transmitted to the English league,
probably via the court
and also by a number of influential books,
which were widely read amongst them.
One of them was a translation of an
Italian Work Castiglioni his book,
the court here originally written in the
1520s and published in England in 1561.
Uh, another, these titles
are on your handout.
Another was a book by Sir Thomas Elliot,
who was a member of Henry the eighth
secretary at a in 1537 he published a book
called the governor,
the book named the governor,
which proved to be a great popularizer
of humanist educational ideals.
A Elliot, for example, laid down
a model of the ideal education,
which suggested the children should
be taught Latin by the age of seven,
between seven and 14,
they would read Latin classics and
begin to learn Greek between 14 and 17.
They would be trained in
logic, in rhetoric, in history,
and in poetry between 17 and 21,
they would move on to philosophy and
ethics, particularly the works of Plato,
which were particularly valued by
the humanists. And at the age of 21,
they would begin studying law and
meanwhile they would also have physical
training,
Horseman Ship Sports,
the military arts and dancing.
Dancing was considered very important.
It taught grace and poise and they
considered that to be an important
accomplishment. Uh, well this is a,
a demanding model of education,
which seems ridiculously
demanding these days to think.
So until I first read the Yale
distributional requirements.
So in a sense, we are in the
tradition. The third work,
which was very influential, was
written by Roger, asked them, uh,
another man close to the court in 1570.
It was in fact inspired by a dinner
table conversation about education,
which you had with William
sessile, Elizabeth's principal
secretary, and ask him,
put it down in writing in the schoolmaster
published in 1570 he described it as
being specially purposed for the private
bringing up of youth in gentleman's and
nobleman houses focusing on classical
learning and sound religion.
Okay,
so renaissance humanism was one model
aimed in particular at the social elite.
A second cultural influence of great
importance was of course the Protestant
reformation.
The notion that learning
and sound religion should
go together was present from
the beginning of course,
but the triumph of Protestantism in the
reformation gave an even greater edge to
the advocacy of education for two reasons.
First of all,
they wanted to educate the clergy better
to provide a better educated clergy who
would be not only administrators
at the sacraments,
but at teaching pastorate,
theologically aware preachers
and catechized as educators
of the people in the
new church.
Secondly,
they also believed that education was a
vital aid to the salvation of the common
people.
Protestantism after all was very
much a religion of the book.
And in their view,
full appreciation of God's will require
the ability to read it in the scriptures
or ideally,
hence there was an emphasis on schooling
and on basic literacy for essentially
religious purposes.
And that in a sense extends the
educational drive of the period beyond the
social elite to the population at large.
This is an educational ideal of
much broader social relevance.
So the educational imperative
then involved too ideological
or cultural elements,
humanist ideals of virtuous rulers,
Protestant ideals of a godly pastorate,
and a godly people of
more universal relevance.
Both promoted formal education as a
means of social and cultural change.
And that's an altogether new significance
for the institutions of schooling.
They envisage social and cultural
change as a result. And meanwhile,
of course,
as background to all of this,
there was the process of
head of economic expansion,
which I've already described,
enhancing in various ways the desirability
of basic schooling for various
commercial purposes.
So what was the response?
One response was the
gradual transformation of
the education of the social
elite, the upper gentry in
particular. And the aristocracy,
the 16th century essentially saw the
transition from a pattern of people being
educated in great noble households
by tutors or household chaplains
to an ideal in which people
first of all attended schools,
grammar schools in particular,
and then moved on to the
universities of Oxford and Cambridge,
the ancient universities,
and then sometimes also to
the inns of court in London,
which were very much like
Oxford or Cambridge colleges,
but devoted to the study of the law.
Sometimes referred to as
England's third university.
Though they were essentially a
separate set of institutions.
Well,
the universities and the Inns of court
got this role in elite education pretty
much by default
in the 1530s various humanist advisers
on education still thought of the
universities. There's primarily
a place for training clergyman.
They wanted the foundation of a
new academy for the social elite,
which should ideally be
located near the capitol,
but such schemes came to nothing.
And by the mid 16th century
members of the social elite,
we'll be getting to follow earlier
precedents of some of their number by
attending the universities and sometimes
going on to the inns of court by the
late 16th century.
That trickle of gentlemen and noblemen
into the universities and the INS had
become a stream and soon it
was something of a flood.
Many of the buildings in
Oxford and Cambridge colleges,
which survived to this day,
we actually erected at this time to
expand the provision for these larger
numbers of students and indeed a number
of new colleges were founded in this
period for the same reason.
There was a massive expansion in
the numbers of students at both the
universities and the ends. In
fact, by the early 17th century,
the numbers of students in
these institutions was at
the highest that it was to
be again before the 19th century faded
a little in the late 17th and 18th
centuries and then rose again later on.
All of this meant a very significant
change in the social composition of Oxford
and Cambridge colleges.
And if you look at your handout,
the set of tables that are there,
you'll see in table one,
the social competition of a
number of Cambridge colleges.
These are the undergraduates
and you'll see that, um,
by the late 16th and 17th centuries to
which these figures refer the College
Emmanuel College had 63% of
its students of gentry birth.
Kings college had 58% of gentry birth
and Jesus and Saint John's just less than
50%.
This was the general trend and it was
pretty much the same story at Oxford.
Well,
the university has had to
adapt to educating these
new types of students and a
new pattern sooner emerged.
Many of these gentry students,
um,
lived in their colleges as what
were known as fellow commoners.
They ate with the master and fellows
of the college on the high table rather
than down in the body of the
hall with more Plebeian students.
They were also very rarely involved
in actually taking a degree.
Most of them pursued that
studies privately with
tutors who were appointed by
their parents within particular
colleges to oversee their education,
to look after their moral welfare.
And they were paid directly
by the parents to do this.
It's the origins of the Oxford and
Cambridge tutorial system at this time.
In fact, many of these students
even slept in their tutors rooms.
There would be a number of little
trickle beds they were called.
They could be pushed in to the,
to the wall and pulled out at night where
these students would sleep with their
master of their tutor
in his room next door
instead of the usual formal
course of the university,
which included rhetoric and logic and
philosophy leading to the bachelor's
degree tutors usually devised
for their students. Um,
more modern courses. They included
subjects like history, literature,
a geography,
modern divinity and modern philosophy.
Um, some of them prepared special
reading lists for their students. Uh,
some of them even prepared for their
students. Digests of key quotations,
sort of 16th century
handouts. You could say, um,
key quotes from the classics that you
could drop into your conversation and they
would help their students
memorize in that way.
Um, we have an account of education at
Cambridge in the early 17th century from a
student called Simmons dues.
Uh, who kept a diary. Um,
his name is there, uh, on your,
on your handout a between 16,
17 and 16,
19 Simmons Jews was a student at
St John's College in Cambridge.
And there we learn,
he studied logic and ethics and moral
philosophy and history with his tutor,
Richard Holdsworth,
who was a well known puritan divine.
He also went to a few of the university
lectures, though not terribly many.
He practiced his letter style
in English and in Latin.
It was very important to
learn to write a letter. Well,
he went to sermons in the churches of
the city and he discussed modern theology
with his tutor and he kept the
theological commonplace book. Um,
he was being trained in Calvinist theology
and he rounded the whole thing off
with what he described as
my often conversing with
learned men of other colleges
and the prime young students of mine own.
Now all of this was in accordance with
the desires of gentry parents to have an
education which was suitable for
learners and polished gentleman of the
Renaissance Ideal Richard Holdsworth
with as tutor put it well, uh,
in a letter describing
one of his students,
he was recruiting someone
else to tutor the boy. Uh,
and he described the boys'
fathers desires as follows.
His father means not to have
him a scholar by profession,
but only to be seasoned with the
varnish of learning and piety.
And that pretty much sums
up what they were aiming at.
His father means him not to have him
a scholar by profession, God forbid,
but only to be seasoned with the
varnish of learning and piety.
The inns of court down in London adapted
far less to the needs of new students.
Um, students got no special help.
There was no tutorial system.
They simply had to read law books to
attend the courts to see how it was done,
to attend formal exercises in the
ends where they would plead cases,
practice sort of mock hearings.
English common law at this time was
considered quite appallingly difficult.
It hadn't really been systematized at all.
It's been described by one
legal historian as a formless,
confused jumble of undigested particulars
successfully resisting all efforts at
simplification or systematic statement.
You just had to learn it all.
Students who tried do so
seriously found it quite awful.
In fact,
Simmons Jews who went down for a further
two years at the ends of court after he
finished at Cambridge,
described as two years at the ends of
court as amongst the unhappiest days of my
life. Those are you planning
legal careers. Bear this in mind.
I'm the historian of the Inns of court.
Wilford pressed reckons that the average
gentleman attending the ins probably
didn't learn all that much of the law.
Nevertheless,
the ends were considered very important
as sort of finishing schools in a sense
centers for all kinds of
informal learning. After all,
they were located in London,
just in between the city of London and
the royal capital of Westminster where
the courts met and they expose students
to all the things which were available
in the metropolis.
They attended plays.
They went to sermons at
the churches of the city.
They hung out in the taverns and so forth.
Um,
one student who came from Dorset
down in the southwest, uh,
a man with the wonderful
name William Freak, uh,
who attended the, at the ends
of court in the early 1620s, um,
has left behind,
uh,
a list of the books he bought during
his years in London at the ends.
And it's very interesting. He, um,
he bought many religious works,
many devotional books, um, but he
also bought books on physionomy,
on Arithmetic, uh, on travel.
He bought history books.
Uh, he bought popular romances
and he was interested in drama.
He owned a copy,
an early copy of Shakespeare's Othello,
but amongst all the books he
bought while he was in London,
he only bought one law book.
And a significantly,
it was a classic little turn on 10 years.
The classic outline of land tenure law,
which would very much the kind of thing
a gentleman like William Freak would
need to know when he returned
to his family's are states.
Now, of course not all of the gentry
did all of this, but nonetheless,
many of them did some of it.
And it led to a significant transformation
of the educational experience of the
social elite. Um, to give
some figures on that,
in 1563
of the members of parliament in that year,
only 26% had attended
university by 1540 16,
40 to 50% at 10 attended university.
Uh,
or even better if one looks
at the justices of the peace
serving in six counties
in 1562 only 5% of them had attended
a university by 1636 in the same six
counties,
it was 62%.
So a real transformation in
the educational experience
of these vital members of
the political nation.
Right.
Well,
a second consequence of these changes
was a transformation in the educational
level of the English clergy.
Don't forget that the university still
remained the major centers for training
clergyman.
Around 50% of university students were
still nonmembers of the gentry and most
of them actually came from clerical
families or so called Plebeian.
Families are in non gentlemen and
frequently they were intending clerical
careers.
They tended to do the full scale
traditional university course leading to a
bachelor's degree and
perhaps to a master's degree
and their numbers were rising also.
And the rising numbers of these
clerical recruits produced a general
transformation in the educational levels
of the parish clergy by the 1630s after
two generations of this largely graduate
clergy was established in much of
England. There are some
figures on your, uh,
on your handout from the diocese of
Wooster large diocese in the West Midlands
in the diocese of Wooster in 1580 only
23% of the clergy were graduates by 1640.
It was 84% and that was pretty much the
same story as could be found in other
diocese at this time.
Yeah.
So the second effect is the transformation
of the educational level of the
clergy.
A third response was the
general proliferation of
schooling opportunities for
the common people.
Okay.
The 16th and early 17th centuries
where a great age of school foundation,
there were many,
many new foundations,
notable amongst them where the
founding of endowed grammar schools,
many of the principals, schools, uh,
in English cities carry
the name King Edward,
the sixth school or some other name
linking them to this period of major
educational expansion and
founding of grammar schools.
In the mid to late 16th century,
there were often founded with
money donated by merchants,
by leading members of the clergy,
by members of the gentry
from particular areas.
And the motivation was often a
mixture of religious seal and regional
patriotism.
For in the county of Lancashire up
up in the northwest here in 1480,
there were only three endowed schools.
By 1540,
they were 12 by 1600.
There were 28.
By 1640, there were 50 endowed
grammar schools. Indeed by that date,
every major town and some,
uh,
relatively insignificant ones in
that county had a grammar school.
Two thirds of the money that was donated
for School Foundation in Lancashire
came from London,
came from merchants and lawyers and
others of Lancashire origin who usually at
that death left part of the money they'd
made to found a school back in their
home county to help boys like
themselves to get a start.
That's the regional patriotism
element in what was going on.
Usually the endowed grammar schools
offered a variety of types of schooling.
The education which they offered,
uh,
was in part classical education as
the grammar school name implies,
preparing people for the universities,
but usually they also catered
for the needs of others. Also,
they had what was described
as the vernacular side
where the teacher was mostly
in English and they often had a petit
section as it was called a petit section,
which would focus on the
three r's, reading, writing,
and arithmetic or while for ours, really
reading, writing, arithmetic and religion.
Yeah.
In addition to the
endowed grammar schools,
there was schools which
were known as petty schools.
These were not usually
endowed foundations.
They sprang up and died away when a,
according to whether or not there was a
particular school or master who opened
them and ran them for awhile.
Um,
but they became increasingly
common all over the kingdom.
Peci schools taught basic literacy,
often accompanied by a
little bit of arithmetic.
Okay.
By the early 17th century,
most country towns in England
had a grammar school and
several petty schools and
in addition,
Peci schools were increasingly
common in many villages,
not unusual for them to be
kept by local clergyman. Uh,
very often the teaching taking place in
the church porch, weather permitting,
all in all. Then we have a
transformation of elite education.
We have a transformation of clerical
education and a vast increase in the
schooling available to the common
people of town and country.
All of this was a very
considerable achievement,
but at the same time, it's important to
grasp that there was some limits to it.
Historians are spoken of an educational
revolution taking place in this period
and I think that is in
many ways justified,
but it also inevitably had its limits
and those limits were most clear when one
looks at the differences of social
rank and gender as one might expect.
If the periods are real expansion of
educational opportunity access to it was
almost inevitably socially circumscribed.
The inns of court,
we're very much elite institutions.
90% of the students were of gentry origin,
the universities as we've seen what also
dominated by the gentry and the 50% or
so of students who were of Plebeian birth.
We're not drawn from the poor
plebeian just meant non gentry.
They will usually the sons
of clergymen of merchants,
the urban elite professional
people and so forth
and the reasons for this are obvious
enough that kind of education.
It was very costly.
Children from relatively humble
families could sometimes make it to the
university if they had a patron who
would help them pay some of the fees for
them.
Sometimes talented children was spotted
by local clergymen are gentlemen who
would help them on their way,
find them a scholarship.
It was also possible to work your way
through by acting as a servant for the
gentry students.
Students who did that were
known as server tours or sizes.
Interestingly,
a study done of them shows that servitors
and sizes working their way through
almost invariably graduated.
Whereas the gentleman they
served of course very rarely did.
Nevertheless,
it's obviously the case that university
education and education at the Inns of
court was heavily monopolized
by the upper reaches of society.
The same was true to a lesser
extent in the grammar schools.
The sons of the gentry might attend.
Most of the other students
were the children of the
clergy and the professional
and craftspeople of the towns with a
few sons of yeomen farmers from the
countryside.
Attending the problems inhibiting the
attendance of children at these schools
was first of all the costs,
fees boarding in the town
where the school was,
but also perhaps even more
importantly perceived need.
This kind of grammar school education
was regarded as appropriate only for
people who would be going on to enter
the professions or trade at a fairly high
level.
It wasn't deemed appropriate for farmers'
sons to get that level of education.
When one gets to the petit schools,
they were much more open and the evidence
suggests a much wider intake in local
society. Nevertheless, there
were still inhibitions.
Fees still needed to be paid,
even if they were small.
You had to supply your own books and
paper and pens and some families couldn't
afford this kind of thing.
There was also the problem of conflict
with the Labor needs of farm families.
Children will often put to school at
the age of five or six per taken away at
the age of seven when they were able
to play a more productive role in the
family economy.
So sometimes their working lives had
begun before they'd had the opportunity to
gain much learning.
Uh,
one 17th century autobiography
described how his,
his brothers attended school
in some of the winter months,
but we're busy on the farm for most of
the rest of the year. And as he said,
what they learned when
they attended school,
they soon forgot he was kept at school
by his father constantly because his
father intended to put him into
trade. And so he, he, he gained, uh,
a pretty sound education.
Well,
the relative failure of the mass of the
population to participate beyond the
level of the petty school,
if that is fairly strikingly brought out,
when we look at the available figures
that historians have put together on the
subject of levels of literacy.
Okay,
you might well ask,
how on earth can we measure literacy
in such a distant period of the past?
Well,
the usual way of doing that is to get
large samples of people putting their
names to documents and to distinguish
between those who could write their names,
who could sign their names,
and those who simply made a mark.
If you look at the
illustration on your handout,
that's a petition signed by
a lot of people whose names
are there at the bottom.
And you'll see, for example,
on the lefthand side,
a scribe has written in the
names followed by his mark.
And on the left of that,
you have the marks of the
various people concerned.
On the other side of the sheet,
there are a number of examples of people
who had successfully signed their names.
So it's possible to get large samples
of evidence of whether people could or
could not sign their names.
One might be skeptical about how
meaningful that is after all,
one could learn to sign one's name,
even if one was in other ways,
scarcely literate.
But that was very unlikely in this period
to be unable to sign your name was not
a great social embarrassment for
most members of the population. Um,
it wasn't something they would need
to try to avoid. Uh, and again,
the schooling practice of the time was
the children only began to learn to write
once they'd become proficient readers.
So if you've got,
if you had proceeded with writing father
enough to able to handle a quill pen
well enough to sign your name,
the likelihood is that you
were a proficient reader.
Now this may leave out of the count.
Some people who perhaps could read
reasonably but had not learned to write.
And indeed, if you look at
the bottom of that petition,
you'll notice one man's mark,
which is clearly an initial letter.
It's clearly an art.
He was called Richard.
One wonders whether Richard could in
fact Reid and could handle a pen well
enough to make the initial
letter of his name,
but historically do this kind of work,
a very strict,
either you sign your name or you don't.
They know that these
figures are not perfect,
but it's a clear differentiation and
we can compare different areas and
different social groups.
So that's how they do it.
What are the results?
Well,
in the year 1642 massive numbers of
people were required to put their name to
the so called protestation,
both at the beginning of the English
civil wars studying the returns of the
Prato station oath,
which survive.
David Cressey found that something like
70% of the adult men who signed that
document were unable to sign their names.
30% signed,
70% made their mark,
but he also found that it varied
enormously from place to place.
Some places when 90% literate,
some places where less than 50% literate,
and he also found that towns were
very much more literary than villages.
That gives us the broad picture of what
had emerged by the mid 17th century.
Other studies have looked at the
literacy of different social groups in
particular areas of the country and
some of the figures they've produced or
they're in tables two and
three on your handout,
they tend to bring out vividly how
there's a hierarchy of literacy and
illiteracy.
These figures are giving the percentages
of people who made their mark who
couldn't sign their name.
Table Two is a rural area of Essex and
Hartford shirts and east of London.
Table three is the city of London
and the county of Middlesex,
which was urbanized,
so that's an urban sample.
There's a hierarchy in both countries,
side and town.
As you move down the social scale,
Yeoman in the countryside,
only 33% can't sign.
If one moves down to
laborers in the countryside,
100% can't sign,
but look at the differences between town
and country tradesmen and craftsmen and
in rural sample, 42% can't
sign, so more than half can,
but if one moves to the city,
only 28% can't sign much high levels
of ability to sign even laborers in the
city where only 78% illiterate.
So some laboring men in the
city could sign their names.
Okay.
What this indicates in general studies
of this kind is that in the course of the
latest 16th and 17th centuries,
illiteracy amongst the social elite was
completely wiped out to just eradicate
it amongst the middling kind of people,
yeoman farmers,
tradesmen and craftsman.
Illiteracy was drastically reduced.
Many of these people can read and
write by the early 17th century.
If you move further down the social
scale amongst husbandman and laborers,
there's much less change.
Nonetheless.
Some of these people also were
beginning to be able to read and write.
It's not surprising that there's a
hierarchy of illiteracy and a society
structured as this one was.
One could say that the hierarchy of
illiteracy faithfully mirrors the social
order.
Nonetheless,
significant inroads have been
made even low in the social scale.
That's turned out to another
form of differentiation,
not between social rank
but between gender.
The education of girls was of course
also influenced by their social rank,
but at all social levels,
there was a major problem of the
perceived need to educate women
amongst the gentry.
By the late 16th century,
it was already widely accepted that
gentle women should be taught to read and
write, to sing, to play
instruments, to dance,
to so perhaps even acquire a
little knowledge of French.
And this education would
be conducted privately.
They weren't usually sent to school,
which was considered too
risky to their virtue.
They would be educated at home
by their mothers, by governesses,
by the Lady of a household if
they were in honorable service,
in a great household,
perhaps by the domestic
trapline of such a household.
In the early 17th century,
there was a little change with the
founding of some girls boarding schools,
usually in the London area,
but they were few and extremely expensive.
So the kind of education the gentle
women were getting was restricted in its
scope.
Though there are a number of rare examples
of individual girls who got a much
fuller education including
classical learning. Um,
one example is a Lucy Hutchinson,
a young woman who tells us in memoir,
she wrote a of her husband's career,
uh,
tells us that her father believed that
there was no reason why a young woman
should not receive the same
education as young men.
So there were people who had views
of that kind. Even at this time,
though it was comparatively rare.
Girls have lower social rank,
got most of their education for life,
either from their mothers or as
servants in the tasks of housewifery.
A few of them attended
school though very few.
They might attend a petty
school if their parents wished,
but there was absolutely no question
of them going to a grammar school or
acquiring classical education.
The universities, of course,
we're closed to women.
The general lack of perceived need
for girls' schooling is shown in the
invariably high illiteracy
figures for women.
If you look at the figures on the handout,
again,
you'll see that in the rural area,
women were 95% unable
to sign and in the city,
76%
these figures may possibly exaggerate
female illiteracy because it was women
above all who were most likely to
be taught to read, but not to write,
taught to read for religious reasons,
but it wasn't considered
necessary to teach them to write,
so the figures for women may be
exaggerated. Nonetheless, overall,
girls of the middling sought might
stand a chance of learning to read and
possibly to write,
but below that level there
was almost total exclusion.
Well,
to draw towards a conclusion,
what was the overall significance
of all of this educational change?
Well,
with all reservations,
I think these developments
are very significant indeed.
The transformation of the education
of the social elite is arguably a very
significant step towards the growth of
a homogeneous national culture amongst
the ruling class created by a highly
standardized pattern of education in which
many of them,
if not most of of them participated.
These were people who were still
very much at home in that country,
their province,
they frequently spoke still
with strong regional accents.
So Walter Raleigh was said to have a
particularly strong west country accent,
which was noted at the court.
But also these people were experiencing
the assimilation and the capacity to
manipulate a generalized system of
cultural standards and values conveyed to
them through the classical
learning they were acquiring.
And when one reads their letters on paper,
they're remarkably homogeneous.
There's a common range of
reference that they allude to. Um,
it's pointed out in one
recent study of, uh, uh,
a pamphlet written by a country magistrate
on the subject of witchcraft that the
classical illusions, which he casually
throws out and the biblical references,
which he casually throws out
in the course of the pamphlet,
he simply assumes that his readers
amongst fellow magistrates will know what
he's talking about.
They belonged to a common cultural
world based on the classics,
the Bible, certain forms of
Protestant theology and law.
Again,
the transformation of the education of
the level level of the clergy is surely
very significant.
Most parishes by 1640 had what you
could reasonably call a kind of resident
intellectual.
It's a development full of potential
implications for the penetration of the
countryside by the cultural
values of the university.
Through the contacts between
these clergyman and those
whom they served in their
parishes,
lowering the social scale.
The achievement may see much more limited,
but I think one should
think about it positively.
A certain threshold had been
crossed in every parish.
There were at least some
of the common people.
Certainly those of middle rank and some
of those even below that who could read,
who could write literacy was now something
that people would encounter much more
frequently in many contexts of life.
Something they would
use for many purposes.
To give perhaps a silly example,
I once worked on a village in the north
of England near Newcastle on time where
in the late 16th century,
every will survive in for that village
was written by the local clergyman.
He was the only one who can do it.
The wreck chords of the village even
reveal that on one occasion a man who was
dying,
who hadn't made his well send urgently
for the clergyman and they couldn't find
him because he'd gone fishing.
A little girl was sent running down the
river to find him and bring him back.
He came back too late.
The man had died with his dying breath.
He had told what he wanted, his goods,
how he wanted his goods to be distributed,
and we know the story because those who
heard his dying wishes had to go to the
court and declare on oath what his wishes
were because there was no one to write
them down in the same village
by the early 17th century,
there are so many people capable of
writing a will that one loses track of the
numbers of people who are acting as
scribes for their neighbors. You know,
1520 in different decades who
are capable of writing. Well,
that's the change which is taking
place even in obscure country parishes.
Even in such places,
the crossing of the literacy threshold
had opened up possibilities which simply
had not existed in the past.
If one thinks of late 15th century society
as one of heavily restricted literacy
restricted to certain social
and occupational groups.
By the early 17th century,
we have fairly widespread literacy,
uh,
partially literate society,
which was well on the
road to mass literacy.
And if you look at the
final chart on your handout,
there's the longterm decline of illiteracy
right through to 1900 and you can see
that the period we're dealing with is a
significant step forward in that process.
Now of course it was a very long road
right through to the 19th century.
Illiteracy remained closely
related to the social hierarchy,
but there was continuous advance
from the 16th century onwards.
By the early 18th century,
England was already probably the most
literate nation in Europe and still slowly
improving outside Europe.
The most literate society
of the time was New England,
a colonial society,
which had a disproportionate,
a disproportionate number of literate
people amongst those who emigrated here.
And as a result,
the opportunities for a more widespread
participation in the growing literate
culture of the period was
expanding ideas and opinions,
which were first voiced in elite circles.
Could sometimes find their way down
to permeate many areas of the social
structure,
like Sherry seeping down through a trifle.
That's not to say that many
people of humble place,
we're rushing to read the more high flown
products of the English renaissance.
Some of them did.
Some people who began reading simple
things became conspicuously literate and
Hungary for books and went on
to read whatever they could get,
but there was also for more,
for those who didn't have such ambitions
are growing popular print culture,
which catered directly for them.
This period sees the birth
of the tap book literature,
Cheap Penny [inaudible] penny printed
works aimed at a mass market by the 1660s
the most popular form of such a cheap
books almanacs were being produced on a
vast scale in London.
400,000 [inaudible] a year were printed
in the 1660s aimed at the mass market
and they contained all kinds
of information as well as
calendars for people to
use.
Most readers of this stuff would not
have been members of elite society,
but they did have access to some of
the issues and ideas of their day.
Such chapbooks enjoyed massive sales
and they formed also a kind of bridge
between elite society and
the mass of the population.
One of the great collections of them,
which survived was put together by
Samuel Peeps, secretary to the navy,
a member of the highest
level bureaucracy of his day.
But he enjoyed the cheap literature
as well. What does the learner,
it works that he had in his library
and it could be red also of course by
members of the middling and lower orders.
It must have had its impact on the
common stock of images and symbols and
understandings and simple
information of rich and poor alike.
And it fostered a popular literacy
which could be turned to other uses.
If you take the chapbook romances with
their tales of knights and giants and so
forth with were being published in the
17th century and you marry them together
with religion,
with the Bible,
what you end up with is John
Bunyan's pilgrim's progress.
He was someone who was steeped
in this popular literature.
He wrote Pilgrim's progress in order to
provide, uh, a religious adventure story,
which turned out to be the second most
important book ever published in English.
To conclude then,
whether or not we want to talk about an
educational revolution in this period,
the educational changes did constitute
a very significant break with the past,
however limited,
however circumscribed by class or gender,
they did open up new areas of
potential in society and culture.
Something momentous was gradually
happening across the late 16th and 17th
centuries.
Something which I think one can
reasonably say without exaggeration,
was one of the great transforming
processes of the early modern period.
Okay. Right. Well,
next time I'll take up the
political narrative again.
Turning to the religious problems and
political problems of the early 17th
century.